the lofty pagoda
towered above guangzhou harbour as
china's only open port
this was where the world came when they
wanted to trade within the great
qing empire and from the pagoda's
highest and most exclusive floors
the view was magnificent closer by
however
the waters themselves were hardly
visible beneath the anchored ships and
bustling wharfs
scuttling boats and swaying jetties the
sights
smells and tastes of a thousand
different cultures
being bought and sold traded and
bartered
smuggled and stolen
it was the center of the world
and she was at the very heart of it
madame zhang asia's greatest pirate
settled herself comfortably
at an expansive table the breeze of the
rarified upper levels of the pagoda
whistling in her ears
exquisitely painted fingernails tapped
slowly on the arm of the polished wooden
chair
on the other side of the negotiating
table sat the qing empire's provincial
viceroy
portuguese naval officers and merchant
officials
of the english east india company at
stake
was madame jung's vast pirate empire
enforced by a strict set of laws
her colossal fortune gathered through
merciless raiding
and legitimate business and a possible
enforced retirement
from the world of maritime violence but
her adversaries
had far more to lose
the qing risked the continued
destabilization of their whole chinese
empire
pirates having years before destroyed
the last remnants of their southern navy
the portuguese feared the viability of
their incredibly lucrative macau colony
the last bastion of long dwindled
imperial glory
and finally the british stood to lose
the opium trade
which powered their domination of india
the loss of the american colonies was
still raw
the asian empire must be preserved at
all costs
they thrashed out a deal madame humbly
agreed to retire from piracy
stand down her 70 000 strong crew cease
seizing foreign vessels and grant the
ching navy
use of her fleet she was offered an
imperial pardon
full custody of her ill-gotten gains 120
ships
and a high military rank for her husband
she had wrapped representatives of three
of the world's most powerful empires
around her perfectly manicured
little finger not bad for a woman who
had started out
in a floating brothel
[Music]
the coastal areas of east asia are
peppered with tiny islands
secret coves and steep mountainous
looking points
ideal for hiding raiding evading and
fortifying
it shouldn't come as a surprise that
seaborne robbery smuggling kidnap
murder extortion rape slaving sedition
treason rebellion
and revolution piracy in all its forms
has always thrived here in fact the
coastal peoples of the east
may justifiably claim to have been
masters of piracy's art
this is the millennia long story of
those cutthroat villains
philanthropic heroes protectors of the
oppressed
loyal to the death brotherhoods and
merciless scoundrels
of small raids off the coast of korea
growing exponentially in scale
to vast pirate empires acting as both
king makers
and scourges of the people living on the
shore
this is the incredible story of the
pirates
of the east
[Music]
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
magellan have been supporting voices of
the past for a while now with their help
we've got some fantastic
long-form documentaries coming up more
pirates more ancient china
more japanese embassies and even some
surprises
not related to zelda unfortunately
sorry and magellan is a great choice to
accompany our videos too
one recommendation i enjoyed recently
was how china got rich
a fascinating study of the incredible
economic boom
definitely worth a watch to help
understand a hugely important topic
a great companion piece for this video
on one of more than 3 thousand
documentaries available
and you can now take advantage of an
exclusive offer
30 off an annual membership this gives
you an
entire year for less than 3.50 a month
even if you've joined magellan before
and lapsed you can simply click on the
link in the description
to claim your discounted membership
today
thanks
[Music]
on land gan ning and his gang travelled
by riding on horses
or in chariots in certain formation on
the water
they sailed on light vessels linked
together
they also wore elaborate and flamboyant
garments to attract attention
the earliest chinese records of piracy
stretch back to the 4th century bc
and over the coming centuries seabourn
traffic and coastal communities in the
vast ocean which stretches between
current day vietnam
china indonesia the philippines korea
and japan were always a danger of attack
or extortion even the romans of
augustus's time warned of asian piracy
on their most distant sea
charts during the 9th century korean
pirates haunted the coasts of their
neighbors
and every nook and cranny of asian
shoreline had gangs of rough fisher folk
ready to try their hand at seabourn
banditry
but our story really starts in 1019
at the same time as danes were raiding
england on the other side of the globe
george ends ancestors of the manchu and
like the danes the dwellers of
inhospitable icy lands
took to their sturdy vessels and headed
south to raid japan
they rampaged through the remote islands
of tsushima and iki
wiping out the men seizing women and
children as captives
drunk on their success they then
attacked the much larger island of
kyushu
carrying off a thousand more prisoners
an army was swiftly mobilized to drive
them off
but the raiders swanned away with their
plunder
a grim omen for the future but it
wouldn't be long before these initial
raids paled in comparison
to the carnage going in the opposite
direction
prior to 1223 there had been peace on
the southern maritime border of korea
but as the provinces were stripped of
troops to counter mongol raids in the
north
and plague typhoons and extreme drought
struck the outlying western japanese
islands
the starving people of those islands
resorted to attacking their weakened
neighbors
to feed their families the attacks
increased steadily as did the speed of
the korean military response
but the marauder's depredations only
worsened
a formal communication was sent to the
japanese government
the people of the island of tsushima of
your country have of old come presenting
tribute in native products
annually harmonious relations were
cultivated
it came to pass that in the sixth month
of the year of the senior fire dog
taking advantage of the night while the
residents slept they entered a hole in
the town wall
and plundered indiscriminately and
disturbed innocent peasants without end
a number of ships are coming and going
in a disorderly fashion and committing
mischief
what is the reason for this japanese
governmental authorities had been
unaware of their wayward western
subject's piratical activities
and were no less incensed than the
koreans swiftly executing 90 japanese
perpetrators
this swift and brutal act of justice
having the desired effect
restoring calm to the seas
fifth month junior wood ox day a
document arriving from japan
apologizing for the crime of the bandit
ships raiding our borders
harmonious relations and mutual trade
were requested
but a word which would change asian
history had been etched
the koreans termed these pirates weigoo
or wako in japanese
the term by which pirates in east asia
whether japanese or not
would generally be known for the next
400 years
so in 1260 as louis ix of france was
considering eighth crusade
the priest nichiren knelt on the hard
earthen floor of his hut
and gazed through the open door down the
green
pine-coloured valley more and more
in recent times there have been
extraordinary occurrences in the heaven
and on the earth famine and epidemics
everywhere spread across the land
more and more are pressed by famine
beggars meet the eye everywhere and the
dead
fill the eye corpses lie about and in
rose
like a bridge he paused
sighed and set down the bamboo brush the
rain's music
intensified this year a novice nun had
even been found eating
human flesh was it any wonder then that
piracy had flourished
the people had nowhere else left to turn
nothing left to sell
nothing left to reap
nichiren was right piracy had again
reared its head
both in japan and in renewed raids on
korea these depredations continued for a
few years
until the much bigger threat than mere
famine and disease
occupied southern korea mongols
publi khan of the mongols emperor of
china stroked his beard as he considered
a problem which so enraged him
that he had been unable to sleep the
khan had spent most of his life on
horseback
even on elephants and camels but he had
never ridden
in a ship the whole idea of water and
far more so the sea
frightened mongols a desert of water was
far
far more frightening to a mongol than
any hospitable expanse of grass
or sand but five times the impudent
japanese had refused his envoys
the rulers of an insignificant island
realm had unceremoniously rejected his
generous offer to grant them vassal
status
he came to his decision now
was the time to act he beckoned a eunuch
officer
call in the sea men
after nearly 30 years of trying the
mongols had finally imposed vassal
status on the korean peninsula
in 1259 conversely the next year had
seen a reversal of mongol fortunes on
the other side of eurasia
defeat in palestine by mamluk egypt to
mark the maximum westward reach of the
empire
but there was still room to expand
eastwards
japan now lay just beyond the horizon
over the next decade increasing numbers
of mongol troops were seen in the
southern reaches of korea
japanese pirates wisely refrained from
raiding
meanwhile kublai had continued his
invasion of china and in 1273
seeing which way the tide was turning
the yancey pirates zhu ching and zhang
xian had offered their 500 ships to his
cause
these now respectable pirates had become
stalwarts of the mongol navy
planning and commanding mongol invasions
and raids to champa and java
they also provided their services in the
two expeditions against japan
in 1274 and 1281
and indeed the japanese defenders who
had the most experience with naval
warfare were the very people who had
been raiding the korean coast for the
previous half century
pirate fought pirate at sea regular
troops
engaged on land
japanese warcraft being small in size
were no match for these ships
those which came up to attack were all
beaten off the whole country was
therefore trembling with fear
in the markets there was no rice for
sale the japanese ruler went in person
to visit the hachiman shrine to make
supplication he also had a royal
rescript
red at the shrine of the sun goddess
imploring that his country be saved in
exchange for his own life
the gods listened winds blew
and waves raged a divine wind
kamikaze or shinpoo delivered the
mongols and their korean levees
to a watery grave the shogunate's
prayers have been answered
japan remained independent and although
no one knew it the black deaths which
would wipe out hundreds of millions of
people
and spread as a result of the secure
trade and communication routes that the
mongol empire guaranteed
would never reach japan
but the mongol invasions led to a far
greater long-term military deployment in
the western areas where pirates had
traditionally ruled the roost
aware that japan had only narrowly
escaped incorporation into the mongol
empire
the shogunate strengthened by its
military success was determined to keep
as lower profile as possible
piracy for a time died away
in the sea of japan
who were young had been one of the most
powerful men in china
until four days ago great minister of
the left the ming
emperor's chancellor now surrounded by
armored soldiers their guan dao weapons
grounded and gleaming in the soft
morning sunlight
he and his entire family knelt in
nanjing's execution grounds
awaiting death who had been instrumental
in bringing about the rise of the new
ming dynasty
by providing ships for the decisive 1363
battle of lake poijang
which secured the end of mongol rule and
ushered in a new dawn
the great ming da min
who had served his lord and then emperor
hung wu faithfully
and as far as he was concerned justly
ushering in a better governed
more secure and more just nation rid
of the stinking mongol nomads
but who had become too powerful perhaps
occasionally taking the law into his own
hands
and emperor hongwoo's increasing
paranoia had turned him against his
chief minister
who could feel that his days were
numbered and had decided
to strike first
he ordered a servant to japan to engage
a gang of samurai pirates to assassinate
the emperor
they were known to spare no one kill
swiftly without remorse
the 400 pirates disguised themselves as
a tribute mission with weapons concealed
inside huge candles
the samurai had made landfall and were
proceeding towards completion of their
mission
when at the last minute emperor hongwoo
had smelled the rat
and now who was only grateful to be
spared death
by a thousand cuts
he knelt with his hands tied behind his
back and his whole family was
decapitated before his eyes
finally the executioner came for him
as he died he wondered what had become
of the
pirates
whose gamble on mercenary samurai had
all come about
due to another breakdown of central
government in japan
which around 1350 had allowed the wako
to quietly return to their piratical
ways
these raids focused primarily on korea
culminated in outright pirate invasions
involving up to 3 000 men they plundered
far inland seizing everything of value
and carrying off the population
as slaves it was inevitable that china
amidst collapsing mongol rule would also
suffer
the newly enthroned hongwoo emperor
dispatched a letter to japan
in 1369 japanese pirates repeatedly
plunder areas along the coast
separating men forever from their wives
and children and destroying
property and lives if there are those
who nonetheless continue to engage in
piracy
i will be compelled to order naval
officers to set sail
for japan the threat was not carried out
the issue of who were young and his
cabal proved far more pressing
over the next decade thirty thousand of
whose associates
were ruthlessly hunted down fortunately
by the time the emperor hung wu would
satisfy his bloodlust
japan was once again unified under a
strong government
and a new and dynamic korean dynasty the
joseon
who would rule until the 20th century
had smitten the worst of the pirates
the new ashikaga shogunate acted swiftly
to repair diplomatic ties with china
and korea legitimate trade delivered far
greater riches
for less risk time and time again over
the next century
visiting ming chinese ambassadors would
return not only with japanese
merchandise
but also with a sorry looking retinue of
chinese bandits
awaiting death by boiling
peace reigned in the sea of japan
[Music]
[Laughter]
and then in 1517
a whole new gang of rogues hove into
view
off the chinese coast
it was a fine june day when a
strange-looking ship
arrived in the southern chinese port of
guangzhou
the crew were of many unusual races some
with very dark skin and curly hair
others boasting turbans and extravagant
beards
these types of men had been noted in
chronicles of previous ages
the leaders however were unfamiliar
they had skins of violent pink big noses
deep eyes with
thin weak looking hair and declared
themselves representatives of a land
that the chinese had barely heard of
before
portugal this kind of thing happened
occasionally in the unusual new people
almost always came from remote southern
islands so the chinese as usual
called these men southern barbarians
the newcomers were polite at first and
eventually after receiving permission
from beijing
were allowed to conduct an embassy while
the diplomats were away however
the barbarians showed their true colours
[Music]
foreigners from the west called falang
ki who said they had tribute
abruptly entered the bulgar and by their
tremendously loud guns
shook the place far and near this was
reported at court and an order returned
to drive them away immediately
and stop the trade they fortified an
island raided local villages for
children to eat
engaged in street brawls intimidated
other foreign shipping
and worst of all carried out the death
penalty without adhering to the due
process
stipulated by the law of the land it was
clear
that they were in reality pirates
the barbarian pirates were ordered to
leave when the captain refused
they were forcibly expelled for the next
few decades wherever the portuguese
landed or attempted trade
they were fought off and if caught
executed
yasuke stood on deck the fresh spring
breeze
playing on his smooth face in front of
him an island spattered sea
twisted gently between the deep green
mountainous shores on either side
waves glimmered as the rising sun caught
each crest
the giant african warrior was bodyguard
to a jesuit missionary
traversing japan's seto inland sea on
route to the capital
kyoto wherever explorers went the word
of god had been sure to follow
the only safe way to get there was by
ship and by the late 1500s the only
ships that plied the waters
were pirate ships as a military man
yasuke cast his sharp eyes around
taking in every detail of their host's
attire
the pirates went about their business in
rough-looking faded tunics tied at the
waist with hemp and rope
some boasted hodgepodge items of light
armor
they all had swords thrust through their
belts the ships themselves were equipped
with surprising arsenals
small cannon muskets grenades spears
grappling hooks and chains pole arms
sickles
and bows they were far better equipped
than he had expected
there were also strange looking wooden
rocket launchers
yaske had not seen these before and
supposed that there must be an
innovation acquired on raids in china
and korea
despite his size strength and prowess
with myriad weaponry
yasuke prayed that these business-like
killers would not turn on their jesuit
passengers
the japanese seto inland sea had always
been the haunt of pirates
but yasuke was present during their
heyday a far cry from the calm of the
ashikaga shogunate
everything had changed in 1467 the
japanese archipelago had once more
descended into strife
and the shogunate had collapsed in a
brutal civil war
leading to a period of almost 150 years
of constant conflict
the warring states period had begun
the chaos and desperation in the wake of
conflict on the mainland
had led to clans like the murakami
controlling the waves
and the huge seabourn traffic which
passed upon them
they were the kings of the maritime
realm just as other lords commanded
thiefs on land
the pirates ruled from fortified islands
guaranteeing safe passage past their
lairs for a hefty fee
these same men and women would also hire
their own services to land-based lords
and famously even constructed the
world's first iron-clad
ships in civil war riven japan the
pirates were another force
vying to hold to and expand spheres of
influence at the expense of the
land-based lords
warrior monks bandits or ninja their
power
and reputation for ruthlessness was
known
throughout asia
peaceful trade with china by states such
as japan or korea
had been traditionally carried out with
a licence called the kanhur
a tally only the bearer of the kanha the
representative of a recognized tributary
government
was permitted to trade this system had
been functioning since 1404.
kendo sotetsu was enraged he and his men
carrying valid japanese trade tallies
had landed
first a rival clan the hosokawa had also
sent a mission
but they had arrived late to the port of
ningbo and carried
out dated tallies his mission should
have been unquestionably allowed to
engage in trade
the usurpers sent packing but the
chinese trade official had taken
hosokawa bribes and declined kendo's
rightful claim
the samurai jumped up he would not stand
for this
there was a sharp wash and blood
spattered across his
kendo's envoys slew the rival klansmen
burned their ship and chased their
leader over a thousand kilometers inland
unable to apprehend their quarry they
raped and pillaged their way back to
ningbo
laid waste to the chinese garrison stole
a squadron of ships
and sailed off into the blue now it was
the chinese authority's turn to be
enraged
kendo sotetsu's extradition was demanded
it was not forthcoming the tally system
would only work smoothly as long as
there was an uncontested central
authority in the barbarian realm in
question
and japan had no such authority
legitimate trade had continued
sporadically but by 1523
the spiraling chaos had all come to a
head with kendo sotetsu's exploits
which led to legitimate trade all but
dying out
and in 1548 it was forbidden entirely
with trade outlawed piracy became the
only way to fulfill the needs of the
japanese market
this lucrative business fell to a band
of multicultural corsairs
mostly comprising chinese renegades and
japanese mariners
but also including the new southern
barbarians
portuguese africans and other asians
they earned the reputation of being
fearless in battle
often fighting to the death against
forces 10 times their size
rather than conceding the government
established a great line of coastal
fortresses
beacons and other defenses but to little
effect
many coastal peoples took the path of
least resistance giving the pirates a
safe haven
treacherous people from the interior
gang up with foreigners like the
japanese follangi and those from pahang
and siam the evil people of the interior
trade with them
and supply them necessities
in the 40 years after kendo sotetsu's
rampage 601
pirate raids were recorded more than at
any other time in history
and so in 1581 yasuke found himself
aboard
one of their vessels he turned away from
musing on the sea
to see one of the japanese crew gaping
at him
taking in his enormous height bulging
muscles and
ink black skin he was used to ogling
eyes by now
no one in japan had ever seen a man like
him and they couldn't help but stare
yasuke flashed the man a wide grin at
the same time letting his right hand
drop to where an ornate arab jambia
dagger
nestled he would not do any harm to show
he meant business
but the japanese were not alone in their
efforts to carve up the seas
the red-faced barbarians had plans of
their own
it was a warm morning lazily peaceful in
the pirate settlement above the banks of
the cagayan river
on the island of luzon in the modern day
philippines
the calm did not last long
a lookout strum sounded a deep sonorous
boom
a young girl co ran down the low hill
from the palisade to see the prowl of a
huge ship bearing down upon the
riverside pirate kingdom
hundreds of armed men appeared from
nowhere leaping and bounding down to
their boats to counter the attack
before the enemy could land and threaten
their families the great galleys swivel
guns spat laird at the pirates tumbling
down the riverbanks
in the surprise of the moment few
pirates had more than their swords or
spears to hand
even fewer were dressed for battle the
majority were only the loincloths
they had woken in the enemy
approached co had never seen such
strange men their upper body was clad in
shiny steel they wore straight swords at
their sides and held long bladed
spears but the strangest thing was their
faces above ridiculously bushy beards of
red orange black and yellow
stuck noses like beaks deep set
ugly round eyes under bushy eyebrows
took everything in
they looked fearsome wild almost
inhuman they were
the southern barbarians
[Music]
captain juan pablo dicarion admiral of
the south seas and the sea of china in
the navy of the most illustrious philip
by the grace of god king of the spains
and the indies
had planned the surprise attack well
he'd only narrowly defeated the main
pirate fleet at sea
as it returned from raiding china now
the spanish flotilla
bore down on the pirate's nest to
exterminate
the vermin the spanish had established
their first colony in the philippines in
1565
and then in 1571 fortified a settlement
called manila
and set about seizing that lucrative
trade with china and japan
these actions did not endear the spanish
to the locally established wacko
the philippine islands had been the
perfect base to escape the long arm of
the chinese navy
and stability had allowed the pirates to
establish silver mines and prosperous
colonies
some even approaching mainland china for
civilized sophistication
the spanish however increasingly
strident and dominating in their
behavior
were a severe threat and would need to
be dealt with
and in 1574 a pirate called lim hong
gathered around 4 000 chinese and
japanese pirates on 60 ships
and pounced on manila spain had only
just held on and
badly shaken whenever a new pirate
colony was discovered
they sent their increasingly powerful
local forces to pacify the area
and one such incident had been in
cagayan
on the island of luzon in 1582
[Music]
co stood rooted to the spot as officers
from both sides barked orders in several
languages the pirates had declined the
spaniard's offer of free passage
and demanded gold in compensation this
in turn was refused the spanish
frantically dug in on shore
prepared their guns oiled their pikes to
prevent them from being grasped
and prepared to defend their new
position
600 pirates returned to the fort armed
themselves properly this time
and charged the bodies of koh's kinsmen
piled high until there were few left
ko knew what her future held she had
seen it often enough with prisoners
brought back
from pirate raids
following these horrors most pirates
reverted to honest trades
exchanging the goods they plundered or
smuggled in china for gold and silver
mined by american slaves in mexico and
peru
the chinese contraband made its way via
spanish vessels to the households of the
rich
and powerful of europe and the americas
the slave extracted gold and silver
oiled the chinese economy the spanish
managed to secure manila until 1898
and increasingly confident actually
started hiring japanese and chinese
mariners
to man their ships this policy continued
happily
until 1593.
gomez perez governor and general of
manila having all his forces ready in
the province
of pincardos remained at manila with the
admiral gali and having taken in
250 indians of china good rowers without
training them
smoothing them with fair speech and
allowing them weapons as pikes and
swords of japan
which they called katana these good
fellows one
arrived near the isle kaza spying the
spaniards asleep
fell upon them and cut their throats the
governor awoke with the noise and the
captain of these indians perceiving it
and treated him to come out of his cabin
which he had no sooner done
than they slew him and so made a way for
borneo as his thought
[Music]
a lesson in why not to trust pirates
even
handsomely rewarded ones the spanish
never did retrieve the galley
but red-faced steel-encased strangers
were far from the only threat to wacko
for in tune with the wax and wane of
japanese central government
the tide turned once again for
japan-based pirates of all ethnicities
when the warlord toyotomi hideyoshi
subdued japan's western domains
and reunified the country under central
rule in the 1580s
his government was probably stronger
than any before him and backed by half a
million samurai
hideyoshi issued an edict stating that
should any lord be found to harbor
pirates
then his thief would be forfeit he also
provided employment for former bandits
co-opting them to his navy to invade
korea between 1592
and 1598. this disastrous campaign saw
many of the former pirates meet their
ends at the hands of the fearful korean
turtle ships hideyoshi then enacted a
system of licenses
called shuinsho or the million seal
permits
any seafarer of any nationality who
wished to trade in japan
had to apply for one and if caught
without was automatically assumed to be
a pirate
and dealt with legitimate merchants
once again took over where pirates had
left off
another swell of east asian piracy
subdued
but for the states of south east asia
and seafarers passing through those
waters
it was sometimes hard to tell
john davies did not like this heat he'd
always been more comfortable in the
ice-bound wastes of north america
where he had spent much of his
explorer's life trying to find a way to
china and japan
through the north-west passage it had
eluded him so now he was on a voyage
going the southern route
not through magellan strait but around
the tip of africa
and into the indian ocean the famous
explorer was piloting his ship
tiger under captain michelleborn to
china and japan
aiming to be the first english ship in
those parts and lo and behold a few days
ago on christmas eve 1605
just north of java and east of the malay
peninsula they had met a ship
full of japanese merchants in danger of
capsizing
the english seeing an opportunity to
ingratiate themselves with the first
real japanese people they'd ever met
offered to help tiger took the vessel in
hand and the two ships found refuge in
the lee of a small island the japanese
were invited to join the english
christmas meal and they responded
likewise by hosting the english sailors
aboard their vessel
it had been fascinating to dine with
these swaggering asian sea men
laughing and joking together despite the
language differences some jokes easily
transcended cultural barriers
he liked these ruffians and looked
forward to seeing their country that
he'd been trying to reach for two
decades or more one of the english
sailors who had had too much to drink
however
had started poking around the rice bales
they certainly contained something more
valuable than rice
these men were clearly not only rice
merchants
others joined him and eventually the
japanese men ended up imprisoned on the
english ship
where they had been feasting davis liked
to think of himself as an honorable man
and despite the fact that these ruffians
were clearly up to no good
he liked them against his captain's
orders he allowed them to keep
their weapons
davies gazed out on the stunning sunset
the light was failing fast
there came a loud crash from behind him
the door to the pirates prison was
bulging about to rupture
before he could run a warrior rushed out
grabbed him around the neck and pulled
davies inside the cabin
a huge sword to his neck in the cabin
another pirate impaled him on a spear
and charged out using the first ever
englishman to die at japanese hands as a
human shield
davies passed out and passed away
an ignoble end to a great life japanese
katana clashed against english
broadsword
as darkness fell over the floating
battlefield all the englishmen who had
been on the japanese ship were killed or
thrown overboard
but the japanese sailors failed to take
control of tiger and retreated back to
the cabin where it had all begun
they held out for four hours captain
mitchell born
had had enough the ship's cannons were
brought up on deck
and aimed point blank the last holdouts
were literally blown away
so was the whole rear of the ship
tiger's crew having survived the battle
but in unknown waters and too shaken to
continue without davey's expertise
seized two chinese ships to make good
their losses
and set a course for home the english
so-called merchant explorers
were in reality no better than the
pirates they had fought
when it suited them they simply raised
their mask of legitimacy
and took whatever they fancied from
those who were weaker
it was a fine portent for the centuries
to come
the english had come seeking spices at
that time worth far
more than their weight in gold they
could go for tens of thousands of
percent profit in the london market
but they had nothing to pay for them
with
england produced little besides wool and
weaponry the people of the tropics had
no need for wool
and were already amply supplied with
weaponry
but japan was a cold country and their
warriors were said to be the fiercest in
the world or so they said
surely the perfect market for wool and
weapons
and japan had silver mountains of it
sadly for the english this stream would
never become a reality
japan preferred silk and was entering
250 years of unsullied peace
but centuries later england would find
the perfect substitute
for both silver wool and weapons
an irresistible asset
opium and 200 years later
that would turn world history
on its head
[Music]
what is the cult of deus
what are the scriptures on which the
cult's adherents rely
and the terminology which they use who
is the main deity they worship
because the followers of the buddhas do
not inquire into these matters
they are not able to vanquish this
cult's adherence and chase them from the
lands
and therefore the cursed doctrine has
grown
day by day
around the turn of the 17th century
several events occurred to cause a large
diaspora
of japanese to emigrate around eastern
asia
the 1603 battle of sekigahara secured
the rule of the tokugawa family in japan
until 1868
but the defeated samurai fled some
overseas to places where the long arm of
the new shogunate
could not reach the new government acted
to secure its control over the country
rooting out its enemies the ever-growing
strength of the catholics potentially
loyal to rome and not edo
presented a potential threat and they
were encouraged to
recant their beliefs many christians
refused to apostate to ties and were
exiled
others found it expedient to search out
more tolerant enclaves
where they could practice their outlawed
faith manila macau siam
and dozens of other japanese merchant
settlements scattered throughout the
maritime world of the south china seas
welcomed them over the years these new
communities some numbering thousands
became integral to their host nations
trading extensively with japan and also
due to their faith
acting as useful middlemen for european
merchants
but as so often in this era there was a
fine line
sometimes so fine that it was
indistinguishable between legitimate
merchants
and pirates
many of the japanese diaspora had spent
their youth on the battlefields of civil
war japan
violence was second nature when it
suited them
they could speedily transform from
merchant to pirate and vice versa
local powers saw this and often employed
their new subjects
japanese mercenary pirates ended up
fighting and dying in a whole host of
battles and brawls
all over asia in korea a samurai corps
bravely fought off manchu incursions on
the northern border for decades
in 1603 the spanish despite previous
awkward episodes used japanese pirates
to massacre the rebellious chinese
population of manila
many of them also pirates in 1623
the dutch employed a shipload of
japanese pirates when attempting to
capture macau
from the portuguese the defenders
emancipated their african slaves to join
the fight
and the combined dutch japanese force
was driven back into the sea
and sometimes hiring japanese soldiers
of fortune
backfired badly in 1611 a force of 280
japanese men
took the siamese king prisoner until
they were paid off
king song tam seems to have been
impressed rather than repulsed
and he promptly employed other japanese
mercenaries to form his palace guard
and ki among these japanese adventurers
to win honor and high position in siam
was a man called yamada nagamasa
poison poison poison
it had to be poison yamada had felt
himself weakening for months
and now on the eve of his wedding he
felt his life
slipping away as the music and feasting
sounded outside his tent
his bride a beautiful thai princess held
him in her arms
and he looked into her deep brown shiny
young eyes
the old japanese pirate started to talk
he told his queen of how he had
traversed the seas from japan
as a common sailor then pirate risen to
captain hedman
and eventually decorated general in the
thai king's army
his 600 samurai mercenaries former
pirates all
ruled the siamese roost swaggered around
thai battlefields
sweeping all before them none could
resist
this had won him a kingdom subject to
none but the thai
king himself it had been his downfall
he was too powerful somehow he had been
poisoned
perhaps in his food perhaps by that
medicine the king had recently gifted
but finally the japanese king of ligo
the most successful japanese pirate in
history yamada nagamasa
laid back fell silent
died his final breath played slowly on
the young queen's
silky black hair
[Music]
yamada is believed to have reached siam
around 1610
and engaged in piracy in a minor way
before setting himself up legitimately
in the thai capital finally yamada had
become
king maker as king song tam was dying
the former pirate was tasked with
ensuring the enthronement
of his young son nagamasa had become one
of the most powerful men in the country
and was caught in the violence and
strife of the succession
he had failed the young boy had perished
yamada and his men had survived and he
was appointed king of the tributary
kingdom
of ligo on the malay peninsula an
incredible rise
records differ as to how yamada was
poisoned
but some say the fatal dose was
administered
by the princess his new queen
yamada nagamasa pirate merchant
general law enforcer diplomat king maker
and
king died in 1630
he was only 40 years old
with peace reigning supreme in the
japanese islands the shoguns were
increasingly annoyed by reports from
overseas that japanese subjects were
exporting their violent tendencies
it had to stop ever increasing
restrictions were placed on leaving the
japanese islands
until in 1635 no one was allowed to
leave
upon pain of death it was final
and effective the seaways between japan
and the rest of asia once so full of
brigands
was now empty but nature
abhors a vacuum
the year was 1647.
tagawa matsu was a pirate queen
her husband zhang jielong controlled
vast swathes of the south china seas
with a corsair fleet of thousands his
realm was a state unto its own
and had been at least until recently
effectively an almost
independent entity within the great ming
empire
a true pirate kingdom the colorful gold
and red zhang pendants atop the towers
and pagodas of the clan stronghold of
anhai
fluttered vigorously in the sea breeze
as tagawa looked landwards to wear black
clouds of smoke from the burning city
collected over a manchu
army approaching swiftly on horseback
golden dragon banners
billowing proudly aloft a few heavily
armored soldiers still guarded the walls
yet her husband had abandoned them all
thrown in his lot with the enemy and the
still loyal armies of tagawa's son were
engaged on distant battlefields
now the barbarian horsemen thousands of
miles from their northern
snowbound step home approached this
southern bastion there was no help
coming the battle would be brutal and
swift
the defending pirates were heavily
outnumbered rather than endure
the humiliation of being ravaged by
unwashed nomadic warriors
tagawa dressed all in white silk walked
calmly to the edge of the great
fortifications
climbed daintily to the crest took the
japanese
kaiken blade she had brought with her
from the land of her birth
and plunged it into her throat
her body fell from the battlements
the wide sleeves of her kimono
ballooning in the wind the pure white of
her death robes swiftly turned to red on
the hard cobbles
as the shocked manchus looked on
they are said to have remarked if the
women of japan are of such a sort
what must the men be like
it all started in lord matsura's
infamous pirate haven
hirado in western japan
[Music]
snug in the cosy refuge hundreds of
japanese coastal craft a host of chinese
junks and more than a dozen european
ships
were anchored lord matsura's tiny
backwater had become a hub of world
trade
frequented by chinese english dutch
africans indians
jarvans and many more from here the
japanese vessels would load the foreign
goods
and transport them to the vast markets
of osaka kyoto
edo and a hundred lordly domains in
between
millions awaited the goods that matsura
controlled
the chinese in harbor such as li dan
were outright pirates
based here because the ming authorities
were seeking their heads
the dutch and english claimed to be
representatives of respectable barbarian
nations
but they fought each other in drunken
rages like pirates
and even occasionally captured each
other's ships as
prizes the portuguese had been worse
local blood had been spilled multiple
times
before finally being banished in 1561
pirates should keep their violent ways
to unfriendly ports
not safe havens tagawa had been a young
girl when a dashing young chinese
adventurer called zhang jialong made the
busy little harbor his home
they had a child together in 1624 and
were married
geelong was a polyglot and entered the
service of the dutch who were building a
colony in taiwan
as they had few men of their own the
dutch allowed any pirate ship that gave
him fifty percent of the spoils to fly
their flag
and enjoy its protection so geelong
transformed
from interpreter to pirate
by 1627 he had amassed a fleet of 400
chinese ships
armed with superior european cannon and
a private army of tens of thousands
a man with flair he restricted his
attacks to the rich
and styled himself a protector of the
poor he took anyone into his service
and was particularly noted for having a
personal african bodyguard
of 300 men beijing's navy was reduced to
splinters and the authorities were at
their wit's end
there was one last option co-opted
geelong offer him great wealth and power
within the empire
zhang jielong switched sides in 1628
he was now a ming government man
it was now geelong's job to hunt down
his former comrades and destroy their
dutch puppeteers
he built up a new hybrid fleet of 30
large warships the first of its kind
combining the best of both european and
chinese technology
but before they were complete the dutch
attacked and annihilated the nearly
completed armada
in secret geelong gathered a new fleet
of junks and in october 1633
issued a challenge the dutch of course
had succeeded once and full of contempt
they sailed against him with nine
european ships and 50
allied pirate vessels and as they lay at
anchor
150 small jung ships approached at speed
the dutch primed their cannon they knew
they could blow chinese junks from the
water with ease
it would be like shooting fish in a
barrel
but these were not ordinary ships
each vessel was packed to the brim with
explosives
great destruction was wrought and dutch
power
was broken for good
now the europeans were in their place it
was geelong's ocean
his ships controlled traffic between
china japan the philippines and vietnam
a huge maritime empire vaster
than any other
around this time geelong sent for his
japanese son
the boy later to be known as zhang chang
gong or
kochinga by the dutch was brought up as
a ming nobleman
it is thought that he was the first
japanese candidate in 800 years to be
successful in the chinese imperial
examinations
and was on course to be one of the
highest ranking officials
in the land times were good for the jung
clan
their wealth grew so large some said
they were the richest family in china
then came 1644.
manchu tribesmen from north of the great
wall menacing the border for decades
finally took beijing the emperor hanged
himself the manchus proclaimed a new
qing dynasty
and the ming forces retreated southwards
the jung took a fiercely loyalist line
to their employers
and the city after city fell they
prepared to defend their home provinces
kochinga was forced to leave his
scholar's life and take up arms
his mother tagawa matsu with whom he had
an extremely close bond
made the journey from japan to take up
residence in the family citadel
of anhai
then again geelong defected
the qing offered him lordship over the
southern provinces and he accepted
but kochinga fought on and the qing
withdrew their offer
manchu troops came for geelong and only
his african bodyguard remained with him
massacred in a heroic class stand
jalong was taken to beijing as a hostage
and beheaded like a common criminal
after his father's betrayal and his
mother's suicide cochinga continued the
fight against the manchu for 15 years
the wheel of fortune had turned the
pirate father had become a lord
the noble son was now declared a pirate
coaching knew he had to establish a safe
base from which to plan
a long-term ming reconquest and in 1661
decided upon the island his father had
done so much to cultivate
taiwan where the dutch retained their
prosperous colony
this island was the dominion of my
father and should descend to none other
than myself foreigners must
go the dutch had never had to face a
force like koching's pirate army before
the siege lasted nearly a year brutal
fighting devastating bombardment
near starvation and torture finally
a white flag fluttered above the broken
fortress and the survivors were allowed
to leave
the dutch era on taiwan was at an end
and kochinga declared a new realm the
kingdom
of tongning the qing could not compete
with the jung navy
so they chose to cut off all supplies
enforcing a great clearance of the whole
coastal region
millions of people were forced to
destroy their property and move inland
anyone caught beyond the boundary was
executed
thousands perished millions starved
the ban outlived cochinga the great
pirate
imperial loyalist scholar freedom
fighter and tyrant
died of malaria in 1662 at the age of
37.
he had been about to invade the
philippines to extend his anti-ching
base
had the tiny mosquito not bitten him he
would have almost certainly
succeeded such small things
are what history hinges on
his son zhang jing succeeded him and
died in 1681
his grandson jungkook xuang surrendered
to the qing
in 1683. the qing ruled a unified china
until 1911. the house of zhang was
finished as an independent entity
subsumed within the empire but the
memory
and fear of the sea people remained
and less than 100 years later the power
of piracy
was to have one last hurrah
[Music]
opium has a harm opium is a poison
undermining our good customs and
morality
its use is prohibited by law
increasingly over the next century
europeans people who the ching regarded
as little better than pirates
had been arriving in china's ports
requesting trade
limited access to the southern port of
guangzhou was tolerated
and european trade steadily increased
out of sight
and out of mind of the north china-based
government
europeans had little that the qing
empire needed and were forced to pay for
chinese products in silver
something which was often in short
supply and very expensive to source
it was then the english east india
company hit on the idea of smuggling
the highly addictive deadly not to
mention illegal drug
opium from india to china selling it for
chinese silver
and then using that silver to buy the
chinese luxury produce
such as tea silk and porcelain which
sold so well at home
thus the poppy seed of the qing's
eventual downfall
arrived in ever-increasing quantities in
guangzhou
and the population fell ever deeper into
the clutches
of opium addiction the british who
ruthlessly suppressed piracy in their
own territory
had transformed themselves into the
world's most prolific
drug smugglers and yet just prior to
this
this illicit trade had almost come
toppling down
and all thanks to one woman jung shi
the most infamous and successful female
pirate
in history
in the late 18th century vietnam was
convulsed by revolution
and civil war the tae-san rebels in the
north
and the wynne lords of the south both
saw it as expedient to hire
chinese pirates from guangdong to
further their course
with time the nascent taison state
became yet another
east asian piratical realm
the rebellion was finally quelled by the
win in 1802
and the last of the pirates fled back to
china leaving a new dynasty
which would rule until 1945
but these battle-hardened pirate
refugees did not simply disband
a captain called zhang yi rallied the
refugee pirates around
his flag and swiftly gathered a huge
fleet
this jung had only the year before
fallen in love with a young girl
from a floating guangdong brothel the
girl's true birth name is lost to
history
but thanks to their partnership she
became known
as jiangxi madame
pirat wives do not normally grace the
pages of history books
indeed most pirates did not have wives
but madame zhang was no normal wife
from the beginning she shared the
business of managing the maritime
bandits and the gangs thrived under the
pair's joint command by 1804 their fleet
comprised
400 ships and later at its height triple
that number
employing 70 000 men under arms
their business was both protection in
the time-honored pirate manor but also
plunder human trafficking and after
rendering the qing government's navy
useless
the purveyors of a huge salt monopoly
the innocuous sounding condiment was in
fact a hugely valuable commodity without
which
china could not function so control of
salt brought unimaginable
economic power the pirates had been able
to impose a food tax
on the whole of southern china zhang yi
had abducted a young fisher boy called
zhang bao
in 1798 the pirate couple formally
adopted him as their son and heir
when the father and husband yi died in
1807
with the support of senior captains lady
zhang
took over and quickly married her
adoptive son
to cement the command
[Music]
for years past the documents from canton
have noticed the alarming state of the
coasts of china in possession of the
pirates
not a few strangling banditi hiding
themselves in creeks and
unfrequented harbours of the islands but
a formidable
organized body commanded by daring
officers and certainly
in complete possession of the whole
coast the marine department at canton
employed for the destruction of these
banditi in the beginning
shared the plunder till the pirates
feeling their own superiority
put an end to this useless association
and beat them from the field
under lady jung's leadership strict laws
were enforced
any independent action without her
command meant death
any stealing from the communal pot or
friendly villagers
meant a similar fate as did mistreating
or raping female captives
before this the absolute norm her rule
was absolute the government was in
despair
their force was disabled by the pirates
superior vietnam built vessels
and what was left was immobilized with
fear the pirates judicious use of bribes
ensured that they were always one step
ahead of the law
even when on land for years they
controlled all
shipping even foreign as the european
merchants the east india company prime
among them
found it easier to pay the pirate tax
rather than have their opium seized
but in 1809 lady jung
went too far a thai diplomatic mission
from siam was kidnapped and held to
ransom
american merchantmen were forced to seek
protection in macau
and a portuguese ship which had refused
to pay the pirate tax
was seized the crew paid with their
heads
the government of macau a portuguese
outpost since the 16th century
had had enough they mobilized
for war the first battle in september
1809
had been an unfortunate wake-up call for
the pirates
only three portuguese vessels had easily
held off 200 of madame chung's ships
the pirates had never actually fought
western ships before
they'd never needed to their vast
numbers had deterred retaliation
the portuguese weaponry which included
cutting-edge exploding shells
had taken jung's men by surprise at the
coming of night
they scuttled away
the qing government noted the portuguese
victory
and saw a way to rid themselves of zhang
shi
and her minions they proposed an
alliance
but jung heard of the plan and sent her
ships to prevent the two fleets
combining forces
it had worked but the losses had been
brutal
[Music]
madame zhang lay back in her grand bed
she was dying and she knew it around her
were gathered in numerous
and adoring family they had heard the
stories a hundred times before
but they would endure one final time for
the dying dame
jung told of her last battle in 1810 how
the pirates had mobilized 300
ships 1500 guns and 20 000 men
to smite their portuguese foe how in the
end their grandmother's glorious
flagship
a floating temple pagoda which dwarfed
even the portuguese warships
had been blown to the land of the gods
her pirates
had fled for the last time then
came her cackle but we won
in 1810 atop a pagoda as close to the
heavens as a living woman can get
i dealt with three governments and they
gave me
all i wanted and my men kept their lives
and their riches
their families welcomed them home with
open arms
madame jung prostitute pirate great dame
of the south china seas
lived out the final decades of her life
raising her family
and fleecing the locals in a macau
gambling house
she breathed her last in 1844
there never had been and never would be
again
a pirate like her
[Music]
piracy has shaped all the coastal
peoples of the far east
japan china the koreas vietnam and the
philippines
raised up great rulers dashed whole
dynasties
the pirates were men and women
marginalized from mainstream society and
economic
opportunities they were criminals
cutthroats
and even regarded as something less than
fully human by those who clung to the
land
they would have described themselves in
polar opposite terms of course
freedom fighters revolutionaries
pioneers
time and time again in east asia pirates
became powerful enough to hold great
nations to ransom
and eventually in lieu of victory
governments often embraced the sea
brigands
and their skills to defend the very
states they had brought to their knees
and throughout it all the common people
both suffered as victims
and thrived as perpetrators
piracy did not entirely cease with
madame chung's surrender
minor bandits of one sort or another
prowled asia's waterways well into the
20th century
and the gunboat diplomacy engaged in by
the great powers of the 19th and early
20th centuries
looks suspiciously like piracy when we
look back at it
in the modern age but pirates never
again had the power to determine
international destinies
and we are unlikely to ever again see a
cochinga
or a madam chang the seas where pirates
once ruled
are now patrolled and controlled by six
of the world's 10 most powerful navies
the usa russia china japan south korea
and taiwan the story
of the pirates of the east is now
truly at an end
[Music]
you